How do Americans feel about Melania Trump?
And what about the previous First Lady, Michelle
Obama?
A November poll from Quinnipiac University
provides some answers.
Two years into the Trump presidency, Melania
Trump is still not well known.
In the poll of registered voters, 40 percent
said they hadn’t heard enough about her
to have an opinion.
Of the remainder, more people had a favorable
view, 35 percent, than an unfavorable one,
20 percent.
Men and women had similar views.
Michelle Obama, by contrast, has stayed in
the limelight since her husband left the presidency,
and she is very well known.
In the Quinnipiac poll, only 11 percent hadn’t
heard enough about her.
Sixty-three percent of registered voters had
a favorable opinion of her and 24 percent
and unfavorable one.
Both men and women gave her high
marks, but women were more positive than men,
70 to 56 percent.
Mrs. Trump guards her privacy, and the polls
suggest she has been successful in doing so.
Even three in ten Republicans hadn’t heard
enough about Melania Trump to venture an opinion!
Should First ladies be involved in politics?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.